- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Homeroom live streams.
Sal here from Khan Academy,
very excited about
today's guest Hasan Minhaj
and I encourage everyone
watching on Facebook or YouTube.
If you have questions for Has or myself,
feel free to start put
putting those questions
in the message board
below and we will get to
as many of those as possible.
But before we jump into the conversation,
I'll give my standard
announcement reminder to everyone
that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through donations,
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to KhanAcademy.org/donate.
Also want to give a special
shout out to several
organizations that stepped up.
You can imagine, even
before COVID Khan Academy
was running at a deficit
and then COVID hit,
our traffic became 300% of normal,
and our deficit grew even larger.
And so a special thanks
to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly, Novartis,
Amgen Foundation and others
who've helped us close that gap.
But we still have one, so
any help you can provide
is very much appreciated.
So with that, I'm super excited
to introduce our guest Hasan Minhaj.
I think, probably doesn't
need much of an introduction
for a lot of folks, but I consider Hasan,
me and my entire family are huge fans.
He's kind of one of the actors, comedians,
entertainers of our time known
for "The Patriot Act", "Homecoming King",
he was a correspondent
on "The Daily Show".
So thanks for so much for joining Hasan.
- Thanks for having me Sal.
- So maybe-
- Man, that means a lot
that I mean a lot to your family.
That was a very warm welcome.
- Well, it means a lot
that it means a lot to you
that it means a lot to my family. (laughs)
Let's just start off a little bit on,
I think something that
you've addressed a lot
in your speeches or your comedy,
but I think, especially as a South Asian,
it has a lot of resonance.
I'm suspecting that we're going to have
a lot of South Asians,
especially, tuning in today.
Is this what you expected you
were going to do when you were
a teenager or when you were younger?
Did you think you were
going to be an entertainer?
- No, not at all, man.
Look, I was just like every
other desi kid kid growing up.
I was pre-med, I failed it pre-med.
Then I tried to do pre-law.
I took the LSAT, I lied to my parents,
and then I started doing comedy.
So no, I had no idea that I'd be able
to have a career doing this,
and I still don't fully believe it.
- (laughs) And just to
clarify some terminology,
the word you just used, desi,
it means, depending on the language
in the Indian subcontinent,
in Bengali it's deshi,
but it means someone from your country,
but it generally refers to people
from the South Asian, Indian continent.
- People from the South
Asian diaspora, yes.
- Exactly, exactly.
So what was it, given that there weren't
a lot of other folks
from, we're essentially
the same heritage, from our background
going into entertainment.
What was it about you that you said,
"Hey, maybe this is something I can do."
Was it a talent you had?
Did people say, "You're really funny,
"You should be comedian,"
or just like, that's the life I want?
- No, so look, I grew up
like a lot of kids where
we didn't have cable television at home,
so I wasn't a pop culture junkie as a kid,
but I was really into speech and debate.
That was one of the things I
was naturally kind of good at.
And I found when I was doing
speech and debate tournaments
and public speaking
tournaments in high school,
I just naturally had an
inclination to either
make fun of the prompt or the
person that I was debating.
And every time I did that,
the judges would give me
10 to 15 points higher
because they're just parents
who are bored out of their minds.
And so the fact that like some skinny,
desi kid is making fun of
someone in a high school gym
is really funny to them.
And I didn't realize until
later when I got to college
and actually started
watching standup comedy,
it clicked for me in that
moment my freshman year,
I was like, "Oh, stand up comedy is just
"funny speech and debate."
And so everything else I had
really kind of failed at,
I wasn't that great at it.
I used to work at Safeway,
I got fired from Safeway.
I used to work at Office Max,
I got fired from Office Max.
I used to work at a tech company,
I got fired from that tech company.
Just, I was really not
good at anything else.
- Well, you're a step better than me.
Actually in my first job, I
remember I applied for both
McDonald's and Wendy's and
I didn't even get the job.
So at least you got
your foot in the door.
- You didn't get it?
Did you lie on your application
or were you just like really
straight forward and honest?
- No, I mean, I was just
looking for some extra money.
I don't know why I would
lie on the application,
but yeah, at least you got the job.
I am curious, why do
you think you got fired?
And I suspect you might be exaggerating,
but why did you get fired?
- So with Safeway, I
was stressed out one day
and I just kind of snapped
at work, that wasn't good.
And then at Office Max, I was
supposed to sell printers,
and so whenever someone
comes into the store,
you're supposed to say
"Welcome to Office Max,
"how can I help you take it to the max?"
And there used to be people from my school
that would come in and this
girl that I had a huge crush on,
she came into Office Max one
day, and I just didn't say it.
And my manager was like,
"Hey, you gotta say it."
And I'm like, "I don't want to say it."
"Well you gotta say it," and he really
saw that as like mutiny.
And then I got one of those, like,
"Hasan can come to the back, please?
"Hasan to the back,"
and I was like, "Oh
shit, I'm gonna have to
"turn in my name tag."
- Okay, yeah, so are legitimate firings.
You were insubordinate.
(laughing)
- I was just an employee
Even when I was working,
when I had graduated college,
I had been doing standup for
about four years at that point
from my freshman year,
I'm in my early twenties,
and I moved to San Francisco.
They had a great comedy scene there,
and I worked at a tech company
and I just wasn't getting my work done.
And I remember my manager
telling me you're very capable,
but it seems like you
want to be somewhere else.
And I was like, yeah, I kind of
do want to be somewhere else.
It was a mutual thing where she was like,
"This is not the right fit,
you should probably go."
And then, I mean, you might
know this, Sal, very well.
In Silicon Valley, someone
walks you out of the building.
So like an attorney, like some
sort of like HR attorney guy.
Had to walk me out of the building,
down the street to the
Coffee Bean in Palo Alto
and then gave me my severance check.
It was really weird, and I was
like, "Why did you do that?"
And he's like, "Well, sometimes
when we fire employees,
"people go postal, we have to do this.
"They'll smash computers,
"and we had to do this out of safety."
And I was kinda touched that he thought
155 pound Indian dude would
wreak havoc inside of a...
- Those are the guys you
got to worry about the most.
- Yeah, I actually took
it as a compliment.
I'm looking really big in these mediums
if you think that I'm a threat.
- Yeah, I've never had the walk.
I have definitely been in conversations
where we thought about
whether we had to do the walk,
but then we decided that
that was not appropriate.
We decided we trusted the
person that, you know.
But on your career, a lot of
times when you look at someone,
like yourself and you're just like,
"Oh, he realized he was funny.
"He realized he had a gift.
"He started doing standup,
"and then he becomes Hasan Minhaj."
Did it work that way, or was
it a little bit difficult?
- Now, let me ask you an honest question,
were from the same background.
Out of all your cousins and
out of your entire khandan,
are you the smartest?
You're definitely the most successful,
but were you the smartest?
- No, I would say growing
up, my sister was the one-
- What's your sister's name?
- Farrah.
- Farrah, so everybody's
like Farrah's so smart,
Farrah's the best, right?
Did you ever feel like
everything that you do,
you're just diet Farrah?
Academically, academically.
- Yeah, I would say for about
the first 14 years of my life,
I started to getting Farrah
parody when I was like 15,
but people still didn't see it.
I knew it, but they didn't see it
'cause my brand had been defined.
Got it, yeah, so for
me, look, I had a lot of
really, really smart,
intelligent cousins that,
my little sister she's
way smarter than me.
She went to an Ivy League
school, all of those things.
And so I quickly realized
as I was in my twenties,
I can try to run this race with them,
but I will always a
diet version of Ayesha.
I'm not going to beat her
at standardized testing.
at these certain things.
I'm really good at these other things.
And society didn't necessarily value them,
our community definitely
didn't value them,
but I found value in them.
And I felt like I had a
natural inclination for it.
The same way there's certain kids that
I remember in calculus
BC, they just got it.
Like math, they just got
it verbal, they got it.
They could just ingest tons of material,
understand it, and then
regurgitate it back out.
I had that with public
speaking or thinking about
a quick joke on the fly or
constructing a funny story.
And so I just said, "Look, I'm going to be
"the best version of myself,
"and I'm gonna just go all in on comedy."
And really after a while I didn't have
a high enough self esteem, ego,
or just outlook on life where I felt like
anything else was gonna
work out for me in that way,
so I just decided to kind of put
med school and law school
hustle into this comedy thing.
And then I became very lucky,
that's really what it is.
It's not due to my just
work, I got very lucky.
- But what I am curious about
when you took that leap,
and as we've talked about already,
it's not the standard leap,
especially from folks from our community.
I mean, you really are
one of the pioneers here.
When you started it, did
you have moments of doubt
where you're just like, "Oh,
maybe this was the mistake.
"Maybe my parents were
right," or whatever else.
- Yeah so there were some
seminal moments for me.
I remember 2004, I was
walking around Davis,
that's the town that I grew
up in, I went to UC Davis.
I know there's probably
people that are watching
that are very disappointed, but, you know,
I got a 1310 on the SAT.
So I was at UC Davis I'm walking-
- It's amazing how many people
are asking about your SATs?
I don't know if this is
a thing, but I'm tryin-
- I got a 1310, and we can
include this in the chat,
I retook it on the show just
as a joke, and I did worse.
- It's interesting, it tells
you a lot about our community,
how many South Asians are
asking about your SAT scores.
But anyways, sorry I interrupted.
- The fact that I'm willing to admit it
means that I'm a Vanguard and I'm brave.
- It is.
- They're like,
"Wow, you can admit that."
But I was walking around downtown Davis,
I see the poster for "Harold
& Kumar Go To White Castle"
And I saw John Cho and
Kal Penn on that poster,
and I remember going
into the movie theater
and people were laughing and it was packed
and it was this like
seminal college, weed movie,
which I didn't think was possible.
And there was two Asian leads,
they weren't stereotypical.
And the movie became this cult classic.
And that was one of the
first times where I thought,
"Oh, this is possible."
Then in 2005, my sophomore year,
Russell Peters had a big video
that started going viral of
him doing stand up comedy.
And I had been open mic-ing
for about a year and a half
at that point, and I couldn't believe it.
He was coming to UCLA to perform
at one of their big auditoriums.
And I drove from Sacramento to LA.
I've never told Russell this story,
but I should tell him the story.
I paid $88 and I stood way in
the back of this auditorium.
And I watched him and he
was wearing a white blazer,
I'll never forget this,
Chris Spencer opened for him.
Wearing a white blazer,
and I could not believe
there were 1800 people in this theater.
And he was talking about his family
and talking about his life.
And it just, it really clicked for me
in that moment that it was possible
that this kind of weird,
super power that I had,
it actually was valued by society,
it was seen by society, and you could
actually make a living doing it.
And then the next 15 years of
my life was just figuring out,
am I good enough to actually
make a living doing it?
But I just came to terms with,
I really love the art form
and I loved the craft of it.
- And you were all in,
there weren't moments
where you were like, "Oh,
maybe I'm gonna go back
"to what the family wants me to do."
- Yeah, there were a few moments.
I remember when my LSAT
score was expiring,
that was a big deal.
It was five years after
I graduated college,
and that was a real tough
conversation with my parents
that I wasn't gonna go.
Then they made me go, they made me not go,
but they made me apply,
and I ended up deferring my admission.
And then when they asked me,
"Hey, are you gonna come back or not?"
I ended up turning it down.
And so there were these big kind of
speed bumps along the way,
but I kind of disappointed my parents,
like, through snake venom.
It was about an eight year process
for the venom of disappointment to kick in
and for them to give up on
me and to move on to Ayesha.
(Sal laughing)
- You have kids, right?
How many kids do you have?
- I have three kids, 11,
nine, and five and a half.
- Yeah. I mean, (speaking
foreign language)
You're gonna have to give
up on one of them, perhaps.
Like I got two, I mean, who's
gonna be the golden one.
How many franchise picks do you have?
- That's right, that's why you need,
you need to have a little
bit of a portfolio.
Just so you know, one
to fully disappoint you.
- Distributing your Roth
IRA, you know what I mean?
- (laughs) Exactly, exactly.
Well, what was the moment that
you were kind of accepted?
Was it the gig at "The Daily Show"
that your parents were like,
"Oh, we knew all along
we had a gifted son."
- Yeah. So, you know, 2014,
when John hired me at "The Daily Show",
it was a real seminal
moment for me in terms
of just like respect from the community,
the comedy community, my parents,
because it's very rare
that you get to do things
that are both funny and meaningful.
Like there's a lot of things
that you do in show business
that are just like, just sheer funny.
And then there's things
that are just pure,
like philanthropy, that are meaningful.
And John Stewart kind of
represented the culmination of both.
And the show is an
institution, it's like SNL.
So getting hired to be at "The
Daily Show" was this moment
for, especially my family to be like,
"Look, I think he should
do this as a career."
At that point, I was
already what, 10 years,
one month, nine days into
doing standup comedy,
so it was what it was.
- Two questions.
What do you think John Stewart saw in you?
Was he right?
- Do you mean that as a hater
or do you mean that genuinely?
Like is a positive way?
- A very positive way if I was a hater,
we wouldn't be talking right now. (laughs)
- I think he really loves
take and perspective.
When I knew that Michael
Che had been hired
to join Saturday night live,
there was an opening at the show.
And when I submitted my audition tape,
I just felt like I felt
very uniquely positioned.
I felt like I could be on the show.
I really do feel like
I would be a good fit.
And so I made my own audition tape.
I made my own field piece,
and I sent it to them.
It was almost like a proof
of concept, and they loved it
and they had me come in
and do a screen test.
And I remember for my screen test,
I really wanted to swing for the fences.
And so I took some big
chances and the screen test,
I made fun of John.
I took some liberties even in the script
that I had submitted them,
and now that I look back on it,
and maybe one day I'll
put it up on YouTube
or something so people can see,
I'm really glad that I stuck to my guns.
I made fun of the boss
in front of everybody,
and I swung for the fences.
I wasn't trying to get a single,
I tried to hit this thing over
the fence and get a home run.
- And once you were on the
show, what did you learn there?
What did you learn from John Stewart
or the other folks on the show?
- I realized that take is
more important than jokes.
One of the things I learned early on was
when John would walk into
the 9:15 a.m. meeting,
he wasn't trying to be funny.
He really was distilling his opinion
into two or three sentences.
And then we would build the
entire show around that,
and that's the most
important thing for comedy.
You're making a funny argument,
but at the core what is your argument?
And so great jokes at their essence
are great philosophical
positions said in a funny way.
- And I think that is what
really separated "The Daily Show"
from the rest of the pack.
I mean, in the early 2000s it became,
a lot of people start to realize
that they were giving in some ways
more truthful information
than a lot of what
you were getting in the rest of the media.
Do you see that as part of, when you look
30, 40, 50 years back on your career,
are you saying, "Hey, I'm gonna be happy
"if I just entertained a bunch of folks"?
Are you saying, "No, I also
want to change society."
- Yeah, look, comedy isn't
medicine, medicine is medicine.
(laughs)
So you hear a lot of debates about like,
"Why didn't this song change the world?"
"Hey, if this person was still on the air,
"Donald Trump wouldn't be president."
None of those things are true.
I think art is a true
reflection of the times.
And my goal, Sal, you get this,
I'll button it with this is,
I use comedy as an art
form to understand myself.
And so the work that I do
is to present my thoughts
and my viewpoint of the world to people
so that they feel seen,
so that I feel seen,
and I feel understood.
I want to connect with
people and I want to
explain the human
condition through comedy.
And ultimately I want to say
how I really feel in my heart
and not be a darpok.
So if 20, 30, 40 years from now,
I look back on my life and I
was like, I wasn't a darpok,
and I really said it, I really said it.
And you look back on our show,
I'm proud of our Saudi Arabia episode.
I'm proud of our Indian elections episode.
I'm proud of our student loans episode
because we swung for it,
and that's what it's really about for me.
- That's powerful, and just to translate,
do more technical jargon,
and I'm not the most qualified
person to translate Hindi,
but darpok means
kind of scaredy cat.
- Scaredy cat.
- Scaredy cat would be
the (laughs) the best.
- You look like also one of my ethos is.
Sal, I know you're the Khan Academy guy,
but I also don't want to explain myself,
like I want to be the most
authentic version of myself.
And so I want to make
the world a bigger place
instead of trying to bend
and try to communicate
and explain my culture
point of view to people.
I want to bring you into my world
and make people feel like that.
And so I think that's when
the show's at its best.
And honestly, audiences
are really smart and savvy.
They want to have an
authentic, real experience.
- And I'll say, I'll just speak
for myself very personally.
I think I grew up, I'm a
little bit older than you.
I think I'm nine or 10
years older than you,
but in my generation, so to speak,
it was kind of like, "Well,
I'll just keep that to myself.
"I'll just try my best to fit in."
When I saw your Netflix
special "Homecoming King",
and obviously a lot of your
episodes of "Patriot Act",
there is a little bit of
me that kinda got unlocked.
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah,
that's right." (laughs)
I shouldn't be hiding that as much.
- The game used to be, and your generation
really fought for this where
assimilation was the win.
My generation really I'm trying to say,
"Authenticity is the win,"
and I think hopefully for
my kids and the younger,
I see these young comics coming up,
they don't even need
to introduce themselves
when they walk into the
room and I love that.
They don't even need to
provide the backstory.
I feel like a lot of what the generation
before me was providing was the prequel.
They had to tell the story of our parents,
they had to tell the
story of our community.
And I think now there's a
whole bunch of like young kids
that are out there making
really cool work on the internet
where they don't have to
introduce themselves to the world.
They don't have to carry that baggage.
I think the art that they're going to make
is gonna be even that
much more interesting.
- Yeah, and there's a lot
of questions coming in.
This is from Instagram,
this is Amoogi says,
"As a fellow brown, Indian,
"how do you deal with
racism during school?"
And I'll ask that in a broader context,
obviously race is a very big
topic right now in our society.
And you've spoken about it in, I think,
very interesting ways, especially 'cause
a lot of the dialogue is
around black versus white.
Sometimes people will say brown,
but brown may or may not
apply to South Asians or not.
How have you thought about it?
In a lot of your shows you've definitely
brought up race as a major-
- Yeah, we did a big
episode about George Floyd
and the murder of George Floyd,
and really like the Asian
Americans community,
our community's
involvement in all of that.
And for the longest
time, like you said Sal,
race has been seen as a black
white issue in this country.
And our community has been like,
"Where's our place in all of that?"
And one of the things that
I wanted to explain was,
for a lot of us were descendants
of the 1965 Immigration Act.
So because of that piece of legislation
signed by Lyndon B. Johnson
and Martin Luther King, Jr.,
Our ammi and our aabu's
were able to come here
in the 70s and 80s to get
educational opportunities.
So we could be here and
live in Silicon Valley
and live in Fremont and
Milpitas, et cetera, right?
That was important for
me to connect the dots
and say, "No, we're integrally linked
"to the civil rights
movement in this country,
"and we were CC'd on that email."
So it's our job to be actively
involved in the social change
that we want to see in the world.
- Yeah, what I often
point to family members,
and you've often talked
about even the racism
that exists within our community,
which is sometimes quite strong.
But what I always like to
remind folks in our community
is that our lives would be very different
if not for the civil rights movement.
I think a lot of South Asians kind of say,
"Yeah, we've assimilated.
"We've got these houses in the suburbs.
"We're were doctors and
lawyers and engineers."
But if you did not have the very hard work
of the civil rights movement, one,
the immigration act wouldn't have passed,
but even if our parents
were able to immigrate
to this country, their lives
would have been very different
if not for desegregation
and things like that.
- Yeah, and look, I'm not trying to be,
I think people have these very
intellectual arguments about it
where they go, "Yeah, but look
at what I did in my life."
Really what, a lot of the stuff,
the conversation that's
happening right now
about different communities and people,
folks want to be heard,
it's an empathy argument.
People are really hurting right now, man.
Like unemployment is at an all time high,
people are really suffering
and what's happening right now,
both the social and the, hopefully,
I think the economic reckoning
that's gonna be happening
is people want to be heard.
And I think we have to be empathetic
to hear the life
experiences of other people.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Well, I want to make sure I get enough,
there's so many questions
coming in from YouTube.
So this is from Lizzy Ammabude,
and you know, we talked
a little bit about it.
It starts off with
"Mr. Minhaj, did your
parents support you?"
We talked a bit about that,
but if not, "How did you
get them to deal with it?
"'Cause I'm about to
start studying medicine,
"and I really feel that it's
not where I'm meant to be,
"but my parents," I
think it didn't complete,
"but my parents want me to,"
I'm assuming is what Lizzy's saying.
- I think those tough conversations
are really hard to have,
but I've told this to a lot
of kids and a lot of people
that have turned to me for advice.
When you transition into adulthood,
there's probably going
to be two major decisions
that you have to make.
And they may be really, really tough
to talk about with your parents,
who you choose to love and what you choose
to do with your profession.
Those two hills are worth dying on.
I'll say that unequivocally,
everything else,
everything else just
side with your parents.
They want you to come
there for Thanksgiving,
your hala wants you to do this,
your chachi wants you to do that, do it.
Just be like fine, I'll do it.
Those two fights are worth having.
- That's super powerful,
and what would you say to the,
'cause I know people even,
I've faced it myself,
starting a not-for-profit
caused significant cognitive dissonance.
Doing stuff on YouTube
2005 created significant
cognitive dissonance with my family.
And they're like, "Well it seems academic
"and related to computers,
so that's good.'
But it literally says not profit. (laughs)
It's on you.
- Wait, wait,
there's no money?
Sal, there's no money.
- There's no money.
- No prestige.
- I remember.
- How can we flex on other
people in the community?
This is really bad, why
can't you be like Farrah?
- No, I would like to
claim that I don't have
a fragile male ego, but I
remember going to dinner parties
in 2005, 2000, well actually 2009
when I quit my very acceptable job
as an investment analyst at a hedge fund.
And I go to dinner parties,
primarily South Asian dinner
parties, and I've heard people,
I literally had this one moment where
after I explained what I did for a living,
but I was living off
of savings at the time,
the couple I heard them in earshot saying,
"Thank God, his wife is
training to be a physician."
And you know, that was
definitely a punch in the gut.
- Yeah, but I think if, look, if COVID
has exposed anything, now
that we're all just like,
holed up at home, who are
we stunting for anyways?
If you make major life
decisions that are gonna
impact your life for
the next 10 to 15 years,
like med school, which is
a 10 to 12 year proposition
plus all the time that you have to work
and the debt you have just to stunt
on some random auntie in Natomas,
good God man, that ain't worth it.
Like, it just ain't worth it.
And I remember like my freshman
year when I was premed,
I thought it would be
worth it, but it's not.
And so I'm not saying
that it doesn't hurt.
Like, being made fun of in
the Sacramento community,
that's not fun.
Like being told the decisions
you're making are wrong
or being told, like
hearing people whisper,
"I pray that you don't end up like that."
That's hurtful, but I don't know,
like also waking up and loving what you do
and feeling purpose in it,
I don't know, it means
more to me than that.
- Yeah, super powerful.
You've got one life.
I mean, the time has gone by.
We could talk for hours,
but I'll just let you,
on kind of a final word.
There's a lot of questions
about breaking into comedy,
your inspiration, finish
it however you like,
but this general thing
of life advice for kids,
how do you pursue your passion?
I mean, you've already
touched on it a bit.
How do you keep that sticktuitiveness
to get to where you want to go in life
and have real purpose?
- Yeah, I think, I think a
really interesting thing.
I got two kids, I have a two year old,
and I have a newborn
who's five months old now,
and the biggest thing
that I wanted to change
from the time I was a
kid to now I'm a father,
like the Simba/Mufasa relationship,
is for our parents, they
saw us children as property.
Like you are my investment
and I need to move you
within the S&P 500, the way you need
to return on an investment for me,
I want to look at them less as an owner.
I want to be more as
somebody who guides them
and pulls their talents and
their gifts out of them.
And it's important, if I
was giving advice to again,
16, 17, 18 year old Hasan,
I would basically say,
I wouldn't ask him,
"What do you want to do?"
Because people ask that all the time,
"Hey, what do you want to
do, what are your dreams?"
I would say, write down
what are your gifts.
Meaning, what are the things that you do,
or even if you rolled out of bed,
you would be better than
everybody else in your class.
That's your gift.
And it can be something stupid.
It can be video games.
It could be like two hand touch.
It could be running track.
It could be any of those things.
But what is that natural alacrity
that you have where you're
better than everybody
in your class in your community.
You can just do it in your sleep.
I used to have a friend, we
would play pickup basketball.
He could dunk two handed
in Timberland boots
while he was drinking
Mountain Dew Code Red.
He had a gift for jumping.
(Sal laughing)
You know what I mean?
Like if I had a Whopper
and Mountain Dew Code Red,
there's no way I'm running line drills.
But my buddy Parnell could
just two hand dunk like that
in boots and cargos, and he
had a gift for that thing.
And so I think the key is figuring out
what your gifts are and then
applying work ethic to that.
I wasn't gifted at math.
I wasn't gifted at certain
subjects in school.
That wasn't my gift.
I could work hard at
it, but there's a cap.
And so try to find what your gift is,
and don't be ashamed
if it's a weird thing.
- That's super powerful,
and I think there's
another layer to that which is,
I think there's more
outlets for more gifts
than maybe at any other time in history.
As your story highlights,
in some ways mine,
and many, many other folks right now.
Thank you so much.
- Oh yeah man.
You know what the encouraging thing is?
It's just the beginning.
Like there are people that are on YouTube
that do unboxing videos that are
just savants of their craft, right?
There's people that play video games.
There's so many different ways
to be unique or interesting.
I have a friend who has a great voice
for podcasting, and he
has an incredible podcast.
Like those are things that just
didn't exist five years ago.
And so try to look at what your gifts are,
stop trying to be somebody else
and figure out what those gifts are.
And I think if there ever was
a time to really understand
what those things are, now's the time.
- Yeah, that's super powerful.
And I think, very, very wise words
for everyone listening at all ages.
Hasan, thanks so much for joining.
This was a real treat, I
hope we can do this again.
- Thanks Sal.
- Well, thanks everyone
for joining another,
I thought really, I never know where
these conversations are gonna go,
but I thought there
were some definite gems
of wisdom from Hasan just now
on just how to live your life.
How do you live your life with purpose,
and how do you stick
to what you believe in
and your gifts in the world?
So I thought that was a very powerful.
I'm gonna make sure my kids hear that,
and I'm going to make
sure that I, as a parent,
don't fall into some of the traps
that at least both Has
and I were talking about
that you sometimes see.
I'm super excited about tomorrow's guest,
Nikole Hannah-Jones, a
journalist and author
of the 1619 Project.
1619 is the year that
slavery came to the Americas,
so obviously a very relevant topic
to the world, what's going
on in the world as we speak.
But regardless, super excited
to have all of y'all join us,
and I will see you tomorrow.
(chiming)